let's talk about the big change in the
and the big funny news we got the story
from business insider moderna bioentec
and novavax plunge after biden says the
covet 19 pandemic is over
whoops yeah who what where are those put
options at who was waiting for this
moment congress members
paul pelosi the reason why they waited
five days to air it is because they had
a call all they were like hey everyone
probably dan crenshaw sell your stocks
absolutely
i mean yeah because those folks knew
this was
this is an important story the new york
times did actually a good job they
investigated uh the the inves the
investments of of congress members and
they reported out of 3700 trades they
made over a hundred million dollars with
many of them with uh being almost
perfectly timed so the new york times
actually did a good job investigated and
showed the insider trading that is
absolutely too good to be true for a lot
of these representatives this congress
that got rich off of these stocks